we're at an apartment complex just to
the south of odessa right on the the
coast here and in the early hours of
this morning the residents heard a
series of loud bangs seem to be coming
from the sea and we know that there has
been a russian naval buildup in the
black sea over the past week but shell
started to land here just look at this
impact on the road here with one of the
shells
exploded and when shells hit and make an
impact they're designed to break up into
thousands of pieces of shrapnel and the
effect is pretty obvious to see here on
this building the glass shattered and if
you look closely on the masonry it's
peppered with holes and that is where
the shrapnel flung towards this building
and that is what does the damage with
shells and this morning the residents
here have been trying to pick through
this mess glass just cascaded down from
the building onto the floor here and
they've been trying their best to sweep
it up and i'm they all look pretty
shocked i have to say when you walk
around talking to them and it's pretty
sobering is it when you see the holes in
the ground and the impact that these
shells made and they've been trying to
pull the panes of glass down you know
people living here this is their homes
and you can imagine in the early hours
of this morning a huge explosion a
series of explosions we understand uh
just rocking this place and it's just a
bit further around the corner i've
counted possibly three more
impacts where you've seen similar damage
where the shells have just exploded and
everything in their wake has been has
been shattered now thankfully at this
stage we don't think anyone has been
injured or killed but you know
it takes time for this kind of thing to
to come through and they're gonna go
through the apartments and just check
that everyone's okay i was speaking to a
couple just down from here i can't
really show you because of the big
building blocking the sea but they had a
holiday home and a little owning and
that was just completely destroyed by
another shell impact and the military
are here taking pictures an ambulance
turned up i presume just in case anyone
was injured but this damage this whole
of this front of this building if you
look up at it
you can see
the impact you can see the glass
the windows have been
torn and broken and all they can do now
is just try to repair this damage but
you know for some people where the front
has been completely smashed it's hard to
see
them being able to stay here now odessa
in the south here key port city has been
pretty much on standby for the last two
weeks that we've been here anyway and
we've been seeing the naval warships on
the horizon and it's
it's possible now that they are starting
to
send shells in
and this is the result